على كل حال عصيره العادات بدنا نكمل بهذه
الاخبار فلا يهم ان كنت تصدق اللعنات او
لا سمعتي لا يهم ان كنت تصدقين لعنات او
لا او حتى تعتبريها افكارا في عالم ما
وراء الطبيعه في النهايه اصبحت قصصا
توارثتها الشعوب والاجيال ومن اشهرها
بخلاف لعنه الفراعنه الشهيره هناك لعبه
الاساطير ان كل من يمس قبره بسوء تلاحقه
اللعنه شفتي كيف بحول اللعنات الى فرح
ولعبه وعندما فتحه علماء الاثار السوفيات
بامر من ستالين نفسه لنقل الى موسكو بدل
الالمان عمليه بربروسا الشهيره وتكبد
الروس خلالها خسائر هائله في عام 1973 الى
لعنه اخرى فتح فريق اثري مقبره الملك
البولندي كازيميرو الرابع بعدها مات بعض
اعضاء الفريق تباعا بعد فتره وجيزه ليكتشف
الخبراء اثار فطريات قاتله داخل المقبره
سببت ام
لعنه الماسه الامل ويقال انها حملت لعنه
تمثال اله اندوسيه يقال ايضا ان الصائغ
المجوهرات الفرنسي بير كارتيه اختلق هذه
القصه لرفع قيمتها لعنه مكبث وهي من
خرافات في عالم المسرح هي مرتبطه بالماساه
التي حل التاريخيا بانتاج المسرحيه ولعنه
الماعز مورفي في فريق شيكاغو تسمى ذلك
نسبه لشخص منع من دخول المنيعه من دخول
الملعب ومعه ومعيزه مورفي وظلك فريق يخسر
بطوله متلاحقه
[موسيقى]